[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un paie de l'eau s'il vous plaît
je viens de voir
imaginons on na li qui ont commune
africaine
ici la descendre dans un temps d'une
heure s'offrant dès lors vous explique
en fonction avec deux compris qu'ici à
garder au ghana en glace pas le seul
pont qu'il ne fonctionne pas du coup on
doit leur village à côté
garou arrive à comprendre la souffrance
à lui nous pour aller 35 minutes pour
retourner savions le report n'aurait 10
mai florence et qu'on peut faire
meilleur que google maps temps en plus
bon parfois site a avancé un document
sur la tête
pétète pouvait pas faire meilleur que
wayne mais cette option n'était pas
isolé en plus on est grande
on aimait l'intérieur et le mali va
parfois ou n'est ce pas prendre l'eau
2010l'ancien sony ils sont éclairés le
droit d'avoir le potable mais
aujourd'hui il a des comités ça s'est
passé
ces appels d'amis a fallu surtout dame
d'ingénérie avec centrale de lyon et un
site pratiquement les valides et les
espagnols au cas où vous n'avez vous pas
remarqué l'action et je vais enlever en
afrique il a 5 ans et je suis arrivé
comme transiger c'est pas bien pourquoi
mais je connaissais pas la culture c'est
parlais pas la langue et en foot j'ai
jamais à free connaître m et j'étais là
comme prof d'informatique et c'est sûr
qu'ils les enseignants de la région
aurait pu faire meilleure que moi je
vais arriver en a qui ont des 77
communes du bénin ou pays africains avec
plein de richesses historiques
culturelles au royaume arrivants et avec
des gens extraordinaires comme ça on n'a
mis que je vais vous parler après mais
retournons 2013 on a l'honneur dans les
temps un hôpital de la région
j'ai quitté le groupe de bénévoles j'ai
commencé à revenir et faire un tour et
je vous deuxième enfant hospitalisé par
terre il avait malik
il avait deux ans qui me regardait mais
comme je n'aime pas les enfants de ces
parcs
non c'est pas vrai c'est vrai j'aime
beaucoup les enfants
mais ici pas aussi pouvoir compter en
afrique qui souffre avec des enfants
malades en afrique qui se mélangent avec
un seul pays en afrique qui affame et
qui souffre et c'est ici pour raccorder
tous des histoires
c'était que trois ans après qu'ils
eurent et rooney si vous êtes même
hôpital qui ont ainsi vendu qu'en
réalité l'hôpital hospitalisé les gens
qui ont besoin d'oxygène à l'élite
les gens qui sont pas besoin d'oxygène
les hospitaliser par terre parce que les
gens sont habitués rêver les enfants
adorés par terre nous conte fois ci
connaît la culture et la langue je peux
juger quelle dose istres est gérante
dans l'histoire avec un enfant qui est
mal
il rit l'histoire d'un enfant qui est
bien guéri et c'est pour ça qu ici
aujourd'hui pour vous parler du nouveau
façon d'apprendre à résoudre les
problèmes de plus importante de mon et
simplement dans nothing is qu'il faut
connaître tous les histoires pour lui en
revient vous rappeler le sens maintenant
mon ami il est mécanicien il était riche
mais ni guéri avec des plans ils
commercent avec le sens avec nigeria
pour payer ce titre il est incroyable
avec sam dans la tipp
j'aime à penser avant que sen prix nobel
d'économie qui lisent la pauvreté et au
nettoyage leur dette à long terme par
tout le monde
aujourd'hui on va essayer de voir quels
sont les problèmes les plus importants
de mon prénom
les quatre maîtres économie santé et
pour votre capital santé
c'est aujourd'hui qu'est les pays du
nord et qu'ils ont aujourd'hui dans
examen à nantes et à droite à cette
espérance de vie garantie l'afrique le
continent
je parte s'inquiétait pour essayer
d'aider à 55 ans d'espérance de vie
du coup on ratisse vite qu'il a une
relation positive entre et les droits de
l'homme la ressource on doit avoir des
ressources pour garantir les droits de
l'homme quand l'accès à l'eau potable
prenons la pyramide et richesses donc il
y avait des richesses qui aujourd'hui
nous montre qu'il vit pour sa bravoure
mondial 1 90% des ressources
quand j'ai vu ce graphique j'ai
immédiatement saisi mes occasions comme
ingénieur et je vais demander est ce
qu'ils y entrent en train d'être un
produit de 7 9% de la population
divorçant 90% des ressources très simple
3,5 milliards de personnes dans mon
éducation
pourquoi personnes expliqué qu' à cette
hauteur de pays dans lesquels ils ont
pas accès à ces droits de l'homme c'est
commencer à réfléchir les universités
peut-être ils ont fait pour changer la
société
et pourquoi nous on traîne ils sont pas
en train de faire ça aujourd'hui
parce que aujourd'hui on a une mauvaise
conception devient comment je vais faire
pour mettre à faire un petit jeu rapide
imaginons on n'a pas le droit de l'homme
garantit je vous demandais ce qui vous
allez vous réveiller un jour sans savoir
passer à l'eau potable
qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez crier pour toi écrivait pour la
voir ces temps là des bidasses
aujourd'hui c'est accès à l'eau potable
il avait grandi du coup on va faire en
premier un protest
on va mettre une seule de projeter dans
lesquels à partir de ce seuil les gens
sont pas les miens comment anti à droite
et bien comment supérieur à zéro et
arrosent les biens communs et 0 et ses
graphiques
il est tout à fait la paix a mis des
richesses 70% de la population en deux
pour cent des ressources et services est
de la population aux 4es et 45 % des
ressources
du coup si on pense alors bien comment
comment sommes comme les viandes total
on va se focaliser à remonter la
richesse et c'est parti la population
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si con
samani pris une vipère asturias on
commence à plancher haut bien comment
yves herman on commence à te souviens
comment quand nos publications et cette
saison devient important parce que c'est
au x 14 0 du coup on commence à se
focaliser alésien est la base de la
pyramide et ma vie comme ingénieur
j'espère que grâce à vous
j'ai trois indiens de cette seule à
donner et droits de l'homme à tout le
monde et vous vous allez demander mais
comment son père résoudre ces problèmes
le problème le plus important du monde
il avait le droit international comment
on a t'il le développement international
qui aujourd'hui est en question pourquoi
est ce que vous avez vu un pays sorti de
la pauvreté grâce à solidité de notre
moi c'est pas me sers pays sont sortis
de la célérité de la pauvreté à cause de
la célérité de notre pourquoi parce que
la seule vérité sert à survivre à à
vivre du coup on doit réfléchir à notre
façon de trouver des solutions et c'est
pour ça qu'il a créé or à
l'international en danger d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes avec des inquiétudes qui
essayent de chercher un nouvel modèle de
rang international
aujourd'hui c'est mes droits de l'homme
garantit des accès à l'eau potable
je fais tout ton c'est plus voir de
l'eau potable
c'est aussi et comme ça et je vous
répondrai plus à voir pour vos fans et
non mais bon aujourd'hui j'ai mes droits
de l'homme grandi il a deux explosions
les travailleuses 5 milliards de
personnes qui sont pas les droits de
l'homme garantit donc on a réfléchi deux
façons de faire ça de façon d'apprendre
à résoudre ce problème
vous avez quoi qu'on a pris une solution
pourquoi on pas comprendre le travail
des filles de toutes et tous les élèves
et on commence à travailler pour
résoudre ce problème travail le film est
rude qu'aujourd'hui plus de 40 personnes
dans notre ong sont fait pour changer le
monde
petit à petit on s'est rendu compte des
clics et simple des grosses actions
qu'il faut faire revenant sur miki c'est
à un quart faire part de cette alliance
assure prôner d'applications
industrielles
ce cas montre les endroits où on n'a pas
assez accès à l'eau potable les endroits
à rouges sont des villages dans lesquels
il a pas assez accès à l'eau potable
prénom les qu'alexandrie canaux sans
égale réveille chaque matin
ça aucune ils doivent aller en forêt
avant le lac juste à côté
pour frans de la lacc qu'il a pas d'eau
potable qui est ouvert du coup il s'est
contraint chaque jour prenons le cas des
gants ne varie pas et gare aux cadeaux
du coup parfois leurs conséquences ils
ont pas accès à l'eau potable et prenons
le cas du tac au tac ou si on me lance
zoug où il a deux pompes aux 1200
personnes et que les gens préfèrent
aller en plus ouvert que fram cela la
pop à ce que je vais pas attendre pour
tanner c'est en promenant qu'est ce qui
est des centraliens ils sont en train de
faire trouver des solutions la solution
à un problème qui aujourd'hui sont
garantis avec des technologies
européennes
les pompes qui dépendent des pièces qui
sont fabriqués ici en france
et qu'est-ce qui parce qu'une sorte la
mentalité et on commence à fabriquer des
pièces ce genre et on commence à faire
des technologies à la paix quand la
technologie et ma soeur et à d autres
universitaires qui sont en train de
chercher des solutions pour aujourd'hui
mais c'est surtout la population locale
qui est en train de nous peut pousser
droite
ils ont ouvert un gros pic des pièces
des récentes parce que eddy studio liste
huit heures plus à côté était burkina
faso son pays au nord de vannes a pris
comme outil des pièces de sens avec des
réparateurs forme et on est en train de
donner le potage à nikki est ce que
c'est bien cette phrase des données en
poissons et tout donne un poisson tout
va donner à manger un homme bon jour
peut ainsi y empêcher de manger tous les
jours mais ça reste dans les tories si
on montre aux gens à réparer qu'est ce
qui va se passer
il va réparer le pompe les yeux bruns et
les pompes de ses soeurs et il va pas
réparer tous les pompiers qui ont c'est
pour ça qu'ils on commence à penser à un
modèle économique du raje modèle
économique assez souvent tania social
est aujourd'hui la deuxième tribune a
commenté un script qui sont en train de
donner cet hôpital
on est gay prenons en deuxième quand la
vie dure
carlos estriens ils sont arrivés en dix
ans
on apprend des vous aurez que vous
apprenez des nous quelle france puissant
avec l idée parce qu'ici on parle pas de
la qualité on essaie de nos surprises
on va se croit meilleur que et c'est pas
la solution
aujourd'hui que je vais vous parler le
coup d'arrêt ce seuil est arrivé assez
coopératif de marie sainte marie chaze
une grosse et cultiver des légumes et
maintenant ces coopératives
ils sont trouver ensemble les solutions
soutenable et durable pour la production
des légumes toute l'année troisième
exemple
l'exemple de la journée internationale
contre la violence faites aux femmes le
25 novembre
c'est un problème qui nous pousse tous
ici en france il est en égalité des
salaires entré en f1 de 23% à nikki
c'est encore pire et là des femmes qui
souffre des mariages forcés des mariages
précoces
si vous n'êtes qu'une et s'est
manifestée durant 7 novembre avec la
main droite les droites les femmes est
en train de faire un programme des
radios pour sensibiliser aux gens des
violences faites aux femmes à conduire à
sion je vous parlais mais on dirait un
projet que les procédés mis crypte dans
lequel on est en train d assister de
beurre de karité à des coopératives des
femmes pour les a menés en espagne et
d'initier ces marchés parce qu'
aujourd'hui il a des entreprises
internationales qui serait en train
d'aller sur ces pays et a cédé cette
folie ou rien du coup ces marchés il ne
vit pas les travail des femmes et si
tout est enfin tous allez tous en
famille a sorti de la pauvreté
c'est pour ça qu'il est en train de
faire c'est pratique et vous vous allez
demander pourquoi ces modèles de
développement est différent parce qu'il
croisait sur des problèmes concrets sur
une communauté parce qu'elle est
multidisciplinaire silva dans son comité
on n'essaye pas de résoudre le problème
depuis tous les racines on va oublier
tous les histoires il a légué à la
première histoire avec des stéréotypes
et qu'on afrique qui a faim et que
l'afrique qui a pas accès à l'eau et
toutes les réalités des cinq villages
sont complètement différentes
c'est pour ça que pourrait soulever les
cadres de l'hôpital
on commence à en fixer le pouvoir d'agir
le pouvoir d'achat est les créatifs à
partie et le bris d'égalité
on commence à donner des pistes de
récence on commence à donner des repères
adore et on commence aussi à donner en
production de nourriture se tenait du
rêve pour avis des knicks aujourd'hui je
veux faire une proposition
pourquoi pas on prenne tous le travail
définit tout on commence à changer le
monde
pour quoi faire les étudiants se
mobilisent et commence à travailler pour
ces 3 v + 5 milliards de personnes
les nations unies se sont réunis dans no
milk ans 150 pays pour donner des
objectifs et de leur entourage ses
objectifs avec sept sommets historiques
il nous explique la façon de créer au
monde durable pour tous est ce qu'il
faut comprendre que si on réinvente
doille il faut un développement pour
tous et je vous explique
aujourd'hui on n'a pas des pays
développés et des pays sous développés
pourquoi parce qu'il y en ait mal
développée ici en occident tout est
quasi effacée sur l'excès combien de
kilos et nourriture en gaspillage heures
combien de litres d eau
on ouvre le robinet et ses variantes
combien et lumière dans la rue et la
lune à personne notre technologie tant
qu'il est mal fait
c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient déjà en
droit de nous demander trouver de
nouvelles solutions pour qui on peut
faire les deux rangs pour tous ce qu'est
ce qui est si la même économie émergents
à ces niveaux
l'exploitation des ressources on aura
six planètes pour arrêter excellent
développement et développement canada en
occident et padoan c'est pour ça que les
nations unies ils seront proposés en 4d
travail
et je vous propose à tous les citer tous
les acteurs tous les élèves tous les
professeurs mais commence à travailler
dans ses objectifs des villes durables
parce que les premières générations et
encadre internationale pour sauver le
monde et peut-être on est la dernière
prenons en exemple les objectifs de
développement de l'avenue de 6o pour
tous de qualité
si on commence à réfléchir à des
solutions robinette qui gaspille pas
autant dire si on commence à baisser
un film aussi qu'ils ont pu amener vers
l'afrique dans les pays de l'uma qui
coûtent pas cher qu'on a une origine
hamas
qu'est-ce qu'il passe si tous les élèves
ont moins honte aux dix élèves parmi ces
prêts soit toi toi et toi on commence à
travailler pour les problèmes qu'importe
pour le problème étoiles 2 5 milliards
de personnes
ce que je voudrais aujourd'hui foule qui
voulait travailler pour qui vous voulez
reprend merci
[Applaudissements]